Bernie Sanders wants to become president
but Bernie Sanders also believes in
human caused climate change what a wack
job and Bernie Sanders also believes in
equal pay for equal work filthy dirty
communists and Bernie Sanders voted
against the war in Iraq he's basically a
terrorist but if you really want to know
what Bernie Sanders stands for look at
his donor list Hillary Clinton's donors
are the who's who of Corporate America
Sanders however is in the pocket of
unions that's right unions of worms
working with job standard
their families which proves that bernie
sanders hates corporations and
corporations are America which means
only one thing Bernie Sanders hates
America paid for by billionaires for
billionaires for America from today
every time you buy a bottle of arrowhead
water in California just pour it in the
ground